And it gives me great pleasure to introduce our speaker and I'm mcanulty
hands up if you're incredibly excited about this session over the next 50
minutes or so.
No vrs,
stay less.
Mom was here 15 minutes early.
Hands up.
Who doesn't really know what to experience?
You're going,
what the hell is this all about?
So how many of you would say you just don't really know what to expect?
Hands up nice and hey,
please expect fun.
Please expect a lot of energy.
Please expect a lot of interaction and please expect to be inspired about your
potential.
Is that fair enough?
I'm going to give you a little snapshot just for up by 10 seconds and they're
going to get everybody in this room rocking.
The Snapshot Is,
I'm trying to fit into about 40 minutes now.
What I've learned in 25 years,
I find that a massive challenge.
So what?
I'm incredibly excited,
but yet I feel hugely challenging.
Can I ask you to put your books or your laptops on the neath your church please.
Your mobile phones,
your handbags or your mind bikes,
and you're going to do the following for me.
Can I ask you in the next 60 seconds to meet all the Googlers,
shake their hand and tell them what's your Niamh on?
What do you currently do for Google that is including everybody,
even the guys and girls and Aav on even the guys and girls in McNulty
performance.
You've got 60 seconds to do it,
which means you must do but high energy and a lot of fun.
Let's roll
[inaudible]
love the energy up Saturday.
Love that energy.
The person's sitting on you.
Give them a little bit of a nudge with your elbow for me.
Please give them in a bit of a nudge.
Can we have about 40 minutes with no ego?
Was that okay?
I don't really care if you've got a degree.
I don't care if you've got a phd at own cure.
If you've got a masters or two masters.
I don't really care.
I know nothing about Google.
It's I'm not going to came.
That'll anything with Google,
like a Kim to say or no,
a or B or c.
I know zero about Google.
Is that okay?
So I'm not going to tell you how to do your jobs.
I'm not going to tell you how to do anything better because I don't know
anything.
So I don't have the Arctic as Italia Hodes do anything better.
Is that fair enough?
And just for a bit of fun,
it's a pretty big rugby weekend,
just for a bit of form.
You're going to less than a few little exercises at that.
So Kevin,
everybody,
if I said Taco,
I need y'all up on your feet and it wrote B and a rugby tackle position.
Is that okay?
That's going to look a little bit like this.
You're going to stand up quickly with your up in the already
to tackle.
Is that for,
let's try that out.
I want a side effect to that.
I'm going to call you South Africa.
I'm going to call you Ireland.
Is that okay?
Let's start off with South Africa.
Taco average.
Take a seat.
Okay.
I'm going to call you.
You guys aren't in the water.
We had good passion.
I want really good at Gresham and what we had.
Good sound effects.
Okay,
Taco,
who's going to win this?
Kim.
Okay.
Ready to go.
So give me a bit more sign please.
And this megaphone to the factor of gentlemen,
if that's already on this,
on this group here,
please.
Device shared on need.
You would you bringing your best energy?
Tyco,
you're in a week.
Okay.
All right.
And do not give in to these guys.
Please do not given Taco no brainer if I see ruin.
And by the way,
that's gonna include all the girls in case on the right hand side as well.
And they said,
Ron,
I need you to run faster than your competitor on your left,
your right hand side with your feet on the floor.
Next soap.
Okay,
cool.
Foster opus.
Stop.
If I say engage,
I need you to put your arms Vernie quickly around the gay or the girl on your
left or your right hand side and rich
Taco.
Pretty great at any stage during this session.
If I use any of those,
that'll cous
get a move pretty quickly.
Is that okay?
On a serious note.
How many of you think that seminars are the way we educate people is actually
dead that we know need to stimulate in a different way?
We need to engage in a different way and we need to make it fun.
We need to make it entertaining and we need to make it incredibly stimulating.
If you strongly agree with that,
please scream yes in your native language.
That is of your Irish said an Irish.
If you're a French said in French of your Spanish set,
in Spanish and so on.
If you strongly agree with that comment,
please scream yes and your language go.
I love to hear of Tosh added very loud.
For those who are not Irish tie is yes in Irish.
I know you're all incredibly fluent ours speakers.
I know.
They're actually say some people in the audience.
Your third RSP Taco.
Okay.
This session is not focused on Google,
I hope.
Did you take it as a little gift to you?
Maybe it's a good time of the year to start to reflect on your potential and the
session is 100% oriented towards your potential.
We're going to cover about three or four key things.
One,
your mindset,
I 100% believe.
If you have the right mindset,
then you can unlock your potential,
whether it's in your sporting life,
your business life,
your personal life too.
We're going to talk about your energy.
We believe firmly that whether you're in these sort of scenarios or whether
you're in Google,
you're energy is absolutely everything.
And lastly,
we're going to talk a little bit about your mission and your goals.
We refer to mission like goals on steroids as if you're injecting steroids into
your arms and you're going to chess hard off of your goals as a mom,
as a dad,
as a husband,
as a wife,
or maybe as an employee.
Tackle
the session.
I guess you're,
you are in the right paths.
That's okay.
You are in the right place.
I hope it's okay with you guys.
I would say a lot of you and your Google life,
maybe in your business life or maybe even your family,
feel a little bit like this.
You're going,
whoa.
I may go on to possibly parlance.
I've just bought a house or an apartment in Dublin.
I've just got a team of 25 people and managing 200 people in total across
Europe.
I'm under major pressure.
I'm expected to hit these sales numbers continually and the more seals I had
more what happens ladies and gentlemen and a CEO's role.
The more see we had what happens higher targets and then what happens higher
targets on the higher the targets and where we feel like,
Holy Shit,
how am I going to stay on this?
And then you're thinking,
what about my family?
I'm one of them are friends that I haven't had a glass of wine with for the last
six months and one of them I really,
really best friend that I haven't even met for the last 12 months.
So very often the busier we get,
the more successful they get.
The more we kind that ladder,
the more it starts to feel more like a tight rope rather than a ladder.
If you can relate to that please.
Can I ask you to scream?
Yes and your language?
No,
we've got a bit of a lower tone now.
You realize that session would be a lot of fun,
but also a bit of a serious side.
If I say a change seats,
by the way,
I'm very weary of the people in May.
Right hand side.
I want you to change seats very quickly.
The person who's a slowest to change seats would have a per shops penalty.
Okay.
Please be CFNI conscious per shelf penalty means you're going to be up here
doing at least 10 per shops change.
Okay,
so one of the things in talking to Carlene advanced this session,
Carney,
thank you very much for the work you're doing and Tony Mccartney and she talked
about one of the big things should like those to refer to is confidence.
I last,
I laughed,
Irish rugby camp last night at 1230 and Kardon house after spending a bit four
and a half hours and back to back one on ones with some of the Irish
international gay players.
Then we had a manager meeting talking about the game,
obviously the weekend.
Would you believe a lot of the international stars would come to me in a regular
basis and say,
Andy,
I'm not confident.
Please can you help me in my confidence.
But yet in the corporate world,
we verde very Seldomly get men to come to us to say the need to work on their
confidence.
Women will come to us a lot more regularly and knock on the door and say,
listen,
I don't have enough confidence as a manager.
I actually am not confident enough night and make current role.
I don't know if I'm confident I can continue to grow in this organization and so
on.
So in this session,
hopefully we'll give you a snapshot into how you can improve your confidence.
But what I get to think of Beta,
imagine that everybody in this room for the next 12 months fully committed to
your potential.
What were the impact personally?
What would be the impact in terms of your professional life?
What would the impact in terms of your friends,
what would be the impact in terms of getting the most out of your life,
even getting the most out of your weekends?
What do you agree with me that if you did that you'd have dramatic impact on all
aspects of your life?
We just totally agree with that.
Just raise your hands and clap your hands vigorously if you agree with that.
Go
faster,
faster.
So that's what we're abide.
What a bike hep on your own,
lock your potential.
And again,
I don't know about you ladies and gentlemen,
what I would guess that if you're here by this time next year,
you're going to have to go to here.
If you're a bit more than experience and you'll feel like you're here by this
time next year,
you're going to have to go to there and maybe if you're here and you think
you've arrived or you're starting to derive a bad year,
you're probably have to go back to that.
Whether it's you're just to have your fourth child,
whether it's you're just about to change role,
whether it's you're going to say,
I really didn't look after my body.
I really need looking after my body.
Now I'm up here in terms of where I am and my professional life.
But I'm dying here in terms of my physical fitness and wellbeing.
If you're going really after that,
can I ask you to jump up and cop at the seam time?
Go.
That's a take a sick quickly
terms of mindset.
We're going to give you a quick masterclass and mindset and rather than me
talking igm page Nadya let's do the opposite.
I'm going to ask you in groups of twos with the gay or the girls sitting
alongside.
Yeah,
just discuss three things for me please.
Number one,
how would you rate your main set of 10 10 out of 10 is the best and possibly
could be.
Nine out of 10 is your main set actually is holding you back significantly.
We actually call that main set sabotage.
Okay.
Number two,
please target with somebody who inspires you in life in terms of mindset,
whether that's an amazing female actress,
whether that's your mother,
whether that is perhaps your girlfriend or whatever.
Please talk with someone who inspires you have and main set.
Number two,
and the last thing I want you to speak about very quickly is what's the single
biggest thing holding your main set back?
You must discuss all that and I'm at 60 seconds,
so please go to work.
Cool.
Yeah,
I really,
really love,
love your energy,
guys.
Love your energy.
I love your enthusiasm where any of you ever had something in the last five or
10 or 15 years and you've gotta remember almost every word that was Santa for
some reason.
That impact or that session of that experience,
how to very inspirational impact in your life,
hands up.
If you can relate to that over the last five or 10 or 15 years,
please.
Well,
let's imagine that if this session was they've got for you and your personal
life or your professional life in the next five or 10 or 15 years,
that'll mean everybody will need to be incredibly tuned and incredibly,
let's say engage from an energy point of view.
Is that all kid ask?
So we're going to run pretty fast,
but then we've got a sword right down and hopefully make an impact on you in
terms of your potential.
I wonder if you were to think about main set,
what do you think about something challenging in your personal life?
Would you say it's something challenging at work or where would you start?
I'm going to start with telling you a story.
Okay.
I'm from Northern Ireland,
just across the border.
I'm about probably five males across the border into northern art and brought up
there obviously and my whole life and then eventually moved on the Dobbin here.
But 10 years ago,
um,
when I was a child,
for some reason I was stunned brushing my teeth at the,
uh,
bathroom window,
looking into them or abortion,
my teeth nice and calm.
Nice.
And what acts as a little boy.
And for some reason I get the sense Emma stomach shit.
There's something not right here.
Can I don't know why,
but almost this second sense or this sixth sense,
something's not right.
And others,
Bushman teeth,
next thing.
Okay.
The window that I was brushing my teeth into and the murderer smashed all over
my face.
And again,
remember having glass and when my and going,
what the has after happening,
it was a bomb attack.
The Irish Republican Army had planted a bomb beside my host at home and blue
that the windows into smithereens and the glass literally was in my mouth and it
was taking it to toothbrush.
Shadow.
Am I spitting into the sink with bloating?
The single what has after happening cause it's actually the image of what
happened that particular day they ash Republican Army had killed better
soldiers.
We won't get into politics,
don't worry.
But that particular day or that killed Peter soldiers just very close to my
house at home and a really,
really bad bomb attack.
But that's not the important part.
The important part is I walked into the charter of the home,
but we have a big long card or a bit like the card or through the middle of
where you guys are setting and I walked in and next thing I can hear my little
sister eem or screaming Sarah.
My older sister had already left for school and having outside the House
screaming,
Sarah Screaming.
She was inconsolable.
Screaming and shouting and ranting and raving and next thing Sarah ran back
towards the house.
Thankfully Sarah was okay,
ran back towards the highs,
but all I remember was her lower legs,
blood running down her lower legs.
For whatever reason,
the shop node from the bomb had hit are lower legs and she had a little bit of
blood on her lower legs.
I remember my mother,
my mother was in the house and she remained ice cone,
completely calm,
completely resilient,
completely compassionate,
completely Corinne.
Everybody in the house and the host was going crazy.
Frantic.
What's going on?
What's happening?
The windows were shattered in around the house.
Everybody in the house.
My father,
my sisters,
my brothers all go on frantic,
screaming,
roaring.
She literally never linked.
All right.
Ice,
Kuhn,
resilient,
Caring and compassionate.
She says,
get a seat in the living room.
The living room.
Is it a small room in the middle of the host?
The window wasn't broken.
Get it.
Sit down there on the couch.
She went off on me a tea.
She bought the tee in as if it was any other Sunday.
She bought the D in is any Irish mommy will do,
but the tea and sat us all around tonight.
Calm down.
It's okay.
Put the TV on the background and Sega was there and he's starting to come
through and and use flash or whatever it was.
I was aware before CNN and sky sports sat us all down.
15 minutes later she says to me,
and I'll never forget it,
and have you got football training today?
Yeah,
Mama.
Yeah.
Going,
get your bike.
What do you mean going to bag?
I'm not going to,
you're going to school.
Get your bag.
So she says,
and they're going get your football by going to the screw bag.
Your father is going to take her to school.
So my father,
Joe was the schools and that day at about three 30 words,
seeing them for football like any other day,
my mother and not little instance,
if there's only probably three to four minutes,
give us a life long lesson and how resilient we can train ourselves to become an
adversity and how the impact of your mindset can impact everything in your life.
Even in a very difficult,
challenging adverse environment.
The vast majority of people aren't even top it into a 10th of a resilience and a
10th of a kid belly from a mindset point of view.
So that little story,
even though it was a very short little occurrence,
inspired me for the rest of my life.
My mother is still very healthy.
She's still an incredible woman and she still inspires me in the local community
in terms of their potential.
She was a teacher.
She spent 35 years or relay for teaching young kids,
whether it was an English language,
English literature.
But most importantly,
I think she was a teacher of how you unlock your potential.
So I'm going to devote and dedicate this session to my mother.
Please stay attuned.
Tackle
Ireland are more sharper than South Africa,
very clearly and gage.
Okay,
so you might slip it under that.
So really grinding story.
I wanted the grind yet in that.
Let's make it a bit more positive.
This is a picture of my friend Desi ran who features very firmly in the book
commit.
He spent 25 years and New York City as a fireman.
I know a lot of you are in leadership and management roles and I've been
inspired by a lot of leaders or managers in business,
but to be honest with you,
ladies and gentlemen,
I have never met anybody who's even close to this gentleman in terms of leading
and inspiring,
never even close.
He learned his trade in the Bronx in New York City.
If you're in the Bronx on your head and dine time and an unbelievable cohesive
unit and a fire engine and you hadn't died time expecting to come across really
big challenges,
you're going to learn leadership on pretty quickly and my Gaelic football career
and lucky to have had been coached by on Bay,
but five years he treated everybody equally.
He challenged us every day to be at our best,
each challenges every day to bring our bass energy and bring our egg IOM.
He challenged us to be better leaders and better footballers.
You Pat our man as well as better technically and tactically.
How many of you think that if you had somebody that in your life,
it was significantly allow you to unlock your potential?
Pretty important.
If you're in a leadership role,
that's your role.
Your role is to help other people.
I'm knocked their potential.
Your role is to help inspire other people.
I don't mean at an offsite once a year and an old Google two off sites better
than anybody,
and I don't mean at a Google talk.
I mean on an ongoing basis.
Your role is to inspire people to as he is now,
he's 76 years of age.
He still winning medals.
Belief from kindy.
Kearney is 84 years of age.
He still winning medals.
These guys mindset is incredible.
Always growing,
always learning all with stretching.
The binary's all was thinking,
can they get fitter?
Can they improve?
Can they improve their brand?
Can they improve their body?
What about you guys in the audience?
Do you think you can improve?
Because I would bet you everybody in this audience and the next 12 months,
whether you're a 30 whether you're 25 whether you're 40 whether you're 45 we're
going to have a lot of mountains ahead.
Whether it's mountains in our jobs,
whether it's mountains and our personal lives,
whether it's mountains in terms of financial scenarios,
whether it's mountains physically,
we're going to be encountering those in the next 1224 months and beyond.
The research says we're going to meet adversely about every seven weeks.
We normally say you're going to be diversity,
but every seven days,
that's give you the skills to know how to deal with that adversity.
So if you think about what is the definition of mindset in 30 seconds with the
guy or the girl and your left ear,
right?
Define what mindset means.
Go.
So no,
that hasn't come up for whatever reason,
the screen and what you all do the same time as me to scream nest site and
unison.
Is that okay?
Mindset is,
let me start.
Here we go.
That's a pretty profound definition of mindset,
isn't it?
Think about the significance of that in your life over 2030 40 50 60 years.
If you get your mindset right,
imagine therefore you get your beliefs right.
Therefore you get your thinking right.
Therefore you get your behavior right,
your art look great on your med latitude rate,
but let's flip that on its head.
What have you got it wrong?
I don't want to talk about it.
Let's keep this session really,
really positive.
Let's keep it on getting it [inaudible] very much,
right?
And please imagine this says that classroom that my mother taught in a Northern
Ireland.
If you get your mindset right,
we get our get her attitude right.
We get her.
Get your behavior right please.
All in unison.
We,
we've got her actions,
right,
but get her so most companies focus on results.
Most of the time care,
Pas,
results see results.
I'm bored.
What am I talking about?
Main set?
What a bit.
I'm conference.
Somebody whose main set what a bit on luck in their mindset and therefore
imagine the results the team can achieve on those.
We move towards higher and better.
I'm more consistent.
I'm more enduring performance,
but what about you?
Have you got a growth mindset or you got a fixed mindset?
Growth Mindset?
They're always curious to go meet different people at Google every day to learn
from them.
They actually go out of the way to meeting people that are completely different
on them,
not the same person with the Sim background and the cm language and the cm
preferences on fixed mindset.
I don't like feedback.
Fixed mindset.
I don't get coaching fixed mindset.
I don't get mentoring fixed mindset.
I don't go on those programs.
The HR team are running fixed mindset.
I don't use the gym here and I don't really like it.
Yeah,
it's the best gym and done,
but I don't really like it.
I don't use the swimming pool.
It's actually a smell of Corrine.
[inaudible].
Okay.
I don't want to,
don't go to the person and change here then.
I'm pretty good.
I know them.
They're exceptional.
No,
I don't need to get fed and fed enough fixed mindset.
I want you to just for a minute,
I'm going to put on music.
I'm not going to talk.
I want you to read through these and I want you to Terranea to which one of
those is connected to you and where are you currently are in terms of your
mindset,
growth mindset.
When getting feedback,
a recognize me weaknesses.
They know what the fix fixed mindset.
This worker's boring.
No one likes to do it.
Why are you giving me feedback?
Growth Mindset town did peers,
I wonder,
uh,
I wonder how the data,
let me figure it out.
Can I go and meet them?
A nerve from them.
I have a bottle of beer with them.
Growth Mindset,
fixed mindset that batch ho how's she doing that?
Okay.
Growth mindset desires.
I want to learn new things in Google and I'd say to Google and my sport and my
personal life and my professional life on here affects mindset.
I stick to what I know.
I'm good at sales,
good at management and not a good communicator.
My emotional intelligence and good and never whether good fixed mindset.
I bet you everybody in the audience can relate to either here or here and the
good news is everyone in the audience.
Actually.
Sometimes it's fixed on sometimes where growth.
The key is when we find ourselves here,
it's a drag ourselves very quickly towards a growth mindset.
This is the most par full piece of technology anybody has currently got in this
audience.
That makes sense.
I know you're a Google.
Phones are cool as hell.
I know your technologies could as hell,
but this is far more powerful.
[inaudible] past Master Rana Plaza.
Such ma'am,
please.
One of the things we're doing in the art,
and we'll be set up at the moment that,
but a lot of business teams around the word on people who are elite performers,
one of those as a young lady from spin,
who's an elite surgeon on baby's eyes,
that's a pretty significant role,
isn't it?
I just spent a huge amount of time at the moment develop and her Brian Parr
develop on her mindset development,
her brain's muscle so she can perform much better operations,
much more consistently and much more accurately.
So I wonder how many of you in the last 12 months would say you've spent any
time training your brain?
That's a pretty important most of doesn't it?
So everybody goes,
I'm going to yoga,
I'm going to zoom bar,
I'm going to [inaudible] spinning,
or I'm going to,
what else you use case doing triathlon.
I'm doing that five care at the weekend.
But how many of you are actually training your brain?
In other words,
training your brands a better lead to deal with adversity and to allow you to
unlock your potential hands up nice and a hey,
who's doing any brand training whatsoever up solutely amazing master Ren.
Applause for those guys and girls,
your guys and girls.
No more than five seconds to get the front of the room.
You're going to tell everybody what you're doing quickly run to the front of the
room.
Yes ma'am.
So these guys and girls of all got growth mind set,
get a mint and credit,
right?
Pause.
You guys are going to get these guys to do it but take an activity but you're
going to be South Africa and you are going to be the Dublin team.
Is that fair enough?
So can I have a little bit of space in the middle?
You're South Africa and you guys are going to get them doing almost like that
Icelandic clap like that.
You're going to do it in unison and you you're going to do it and you just send
off to them and you guys are going to be boxing and you guys are going to be
boxing and unison after them.
Does that make sense?
Okay,
ready?
You're in copying where you go.
You're a boxing.
Where do you go
faster on the voice on the wife as well.
Stip and Ryan.
You guys are going to box and you guys are going to do Icelandic cup.
Stop.
Go Fuck.
You guys are going to do I sound a cup.
When you guys want the boxing quickly go
stop
everybody in the room.
Icelandic club one gay.
There is a bit too cleaver.
A screen can help you to set up.
What's your first name?
Yeah.
I'll be a calm gridlock.
Mom,
you're to,
Craig was going.
You're actually going to lead the whole group.
Is that okay?
We're going to need the whole dream.
Okay.
You're going to do the Icelandic Cup from here.
Everybody in the whole room.
How did it go?
That's
fine.
Take a big quick play.
You've got three seconds to get a seat.
Otherwise you're going to be on par shops.
So in terms of your mindset,
guys,
I'm going to give you a,
what we called sesame street.
Simple feedback on main set.
Number one,
be open to learn in the moment.
We always use the phrase,
if there's somebody crazy and your work peers,
go and meet them.
Go and spend time with them.
Meet them for a bottle of beer and there's so many crazy in your community and
be crazy.
I mean,
good,
crazy.
They're thinking and your local community,
if I create an a global business in the same way as the founders of Google were
crazy,
if they weren't crazy,
Google would not exist.
All the major corporations in the world exists because somebody inevitably hard
I growth mindset number one,
be open to learn in the moment.
Number two,
we use the word haunt for feedback.
Does that make sense?
The best people in old performance.
Crucibles are seeking feedback constantly after every performance,
after every meeting,
after every sales call,
after every one on one with their manager,
maybe after cooking dinner for their children.
Constantly seeking feedback and I'm using that one as a funny one,
but maybe that's a more important way.
I'll find that out.
How you're doing at home,
nevermind how you're doing at work.
How many of you can relate to that one?
Please?
Sick and hunt for feedback,
coaching and mentoring.
Hands up.
How many in the audience have a coach that's not even a third of the audience.
The rest of your bestie telling me you don't really value your improvement and
your development.
How many of the Irish she'll get players.
Would it be acceptable to say that don't have a coach are Novak,
Jack,
of which not the habit coach are [inaudible] not to have a coach or maybe even
somebody like Oprah,
not to have a coach.
What do you think or Madonna not to have a voice coach.
What do you think?
It's pretty important,
isn't it?
Because you're,
you know,
you have so many coaches.
At the university or is in corporate environment,
you have to seek out someone.
Then it's harder to seek out different north.
You go outside professionally and you have to pay a lapse personal one.
Ashlyn is probably one of the best Kamogi players in Ireland to give her a big
round.
Oh fuck.
So
actually he's right.
It is easier in sport,
but case that's exactly the point.
Differentiate your sets.
Go and get a coach.
I don't mean to get a coach in here,
but get a coach out of here,
but find a coach who's going to help your weight.
You don't have to pay.
Find somebody in your team who could coach you and you could coach them.
Develop your coaching skills,
upgrade your thinking,
take risks and see failure as necessary.
I guess that's one of the big things about your culture in general.
Do something once a week that scares the life out of you.
We've actually been testing you in this session.
Are you willing to do little things?
It's scurry and challenge and help you grow your conference zones and then
obviously moved towards growth mindset,
continuous reading.
Even Warren Buffet talks about five hours a day and all you guys were doing
favors a day of reading.
I know you are absolutely development and obviously learning Taco.
Yeah.
So what I want to challenge you on is I'm going to challenge you that in the
next seven days everybody put in the audience going to have an experiment,
one ass better.
Your experiment has got to be a growth mindset.
So of your friend says,
yeah,
that's called a salsa dancing and you don't go,
no,
no.
Having a team goal.
One of your friends says that starred the gym next week and that's do a really
good six weeks between now and Christmas.
Yeah,
I'm on board.
I will actually,
I'm working,
I'm working to get the season.
That's another one of your friends says,
let's make sure we do the mark Pollock five care on in the dark.
That's all I'm gonna buy two or three weeks time.
Let's do it for charity.
Let's do what a friends and let's do it with some family members.
Right?
So I'm on furred growth mindset.
I'm going to challenge in the next week as well.
And every interaction you have with your manager or your boss or maybe with your
team say,
can you give me feedback?
How did I do today?
Really important question.
I wouldn't talk about the people who are very fortunate to work with over the
last 20 years,
but it would say there's one big thing to have in common.
They're constantly looking for feedback.
The best of the best of them,
whether it's to a surgeon,
whether it's the elite superstars soccer player with this,
the world class Golfer,
or maybe it's a young superstar female teacher who's incredible and getting
opportunities all over the world to go and teach other teachers.
They're constantly seeking feedback,
so please can we ask you to start?
I'm not journey in the next week.
Moving swiftly forward.
If this lands on Green,
you guys want to jump tracks.
If it lands on red,
you guys want to do boxing.
If Alonza and yellow,
you're going to be doing eh squat jumps and lands on blue,
you're going to do what they called a stork stance.
I wanted to ask you a balance.
Is that clear enough?
Yes,
Mr. Waters,
just get to the music on,
ready to go.
So whenever the color is,
I'm going to give you an exercise.
We already
orange everybody on your feet running on the spot.
Go quick.
Faster
foster.
Okay,
take a seat quickly.
Good.
That's when I hear,
I know what's going to be blue shadow boxing with a partner.
Shadowboxing ghost.
Okay.
We're very fortunate that in the last couple of months,
one of the companies brought us to Costa Rica to work with our global leadership
team for a full week.
They said the global,
each team was actually born,
died.
And the one who spent a full week rejuvenate.
No,
I bet you there's people in this audience who in the last year or two offenders
have your born died.
I bet some of you,
an old people in your teams that are born,
died.
I bet you somebody know people in your families who'd been born died.
And in Costa Rica we got the most incredible inspiration about energy and
wellness.
I'm going to try and get that across the year and about three minutes.
It's sesame street simple.
And Costa Rica at the time.
We're moving naturally.
Going to the gym once a day isn't good enough.
We need to build the movement into our days are everyday is we need to be up
moving constantly if we want to live long,
healthy lives.
That is scientifically proven case.
Whether you absolutely believed that science or you don't,
that's a different story that's related to your main set.
We need to exercise every single day,
whether it's in the gym or whether it's a run,
but we also need to move every single day constantly.
Number one.
Number two on your food at Google is incredible,
but the only problem I've been incredibly as he,
a lot of it eat incredibly well,
but eat less.
Don't fill your stomach's up constantly.
Number two,
number three,
sleep is the number one silver bought it and your health and your wellness.
Number one,
how many of you need to improve the quality and the quantity of your sleep?
Hands up nice and high.
It's a corporate epidemic.
People not sleeping well enough is a major,
major issue.
By the way of your sleep is related to how much you move and of course high
where you eat.
Stress is a secret killer.
One of our colleagues is a cardiac surgeon who says the single biggest issue he
has every single day and performing surgery isn't food.
It isn't a lack of exercise or smoking or alcohol.
It's people in the corporate world who are not dealing with stress.
If you can relate to that,
please can I ask you to have a big deep say for me
it's a big issue and it's not Google's responsibility.
It's your responsibility to manage stress.
So not a young guys and girls in the audience and the guys and girls.
The on,
he's not so young.
A bit like me.
We need to manage our own stress,
take a hundred percent responsibility and then alcohol and I know you guys don't
drink a Google.
I don't need to talk about that one obviously,
so I'm going to try and actually give you a quick master class end to that.
Is that fair enough?
I had you doing the boxing earlier on in your wall is sort of going through the
motions.
What's all this about?
I'm going to show you what happens if you actually get yourself fully engaged in
your life.
If you do all these things incredibly well,
can I ask you to do a little gentle stretches?
Roll your shoulders forwards.
We're going to go to rocky now.
Roll your shoulders forwards nice and gently and roll your shoulders back.
Head to the left and head to the right,
up towards the ceiling,
down towards your navel.
Can I ask you a jog and Mason gently with your feet on the floor
faster but faster.
So what are your set and can I ask you to be boxing as you're sitting down rob?
De Faster,
faster does ease off for a second.
When you get on your feet,
I want,
you're bringing your past energy,
even smiling.
You're boxing with your partners when you have a bit more fun.
So for example,
what's your first name?
Hit it.
I'll be good.
Good man.
Headaches.
Is that what you call it?
No,
it's hidden.
Okay.
Boxing.
Don't you worry.
You shouldn't be slagging me to start slagging me at the end.
Okay.
We're doing boxing.
You should be figuring that out.
You should be using your intelligence to figure that out.
Okay.
Hands up.
If I say one hit number one.
Yeah.
What does that tell you?
That number two,
how's he ever box before you can figure that out yourself.
Okay.
One,
two,
one,
two.
Oh,
oh,
okay.
I'm,
he's going to do it,
but you're going to do it about five times faster than that.
I said,
okay,
so get a partner quickly.
You're in the shadow boxing and too quickly.
Well,
I know what you're saying.
You're too busy.
Look after energy.
See,
I never forget.
25 years ago,
almost to the day a teacher,
Northern Ireland again stood up and said something in an old basketball gym to
all the boys.
It was a boy.
Boys screw in the audience and he said of that had a profound impact on me for
life and literally feel was 25 years.
There's not a week's gone by you that I have one,
three and five or six or seven or eight or sometimes I'm lucky 12 times a week
when we were planning on a very high level.
Okay.
Not a single week on the,
a very significant injury,
desiccated shoulder,
whatever injury or hot.
Okay.
But he said something that had a profound impact on me for the rest of my life.
He said,
how's is the crime on?
Well,
the people's head,
the nobody sees other than the sec.
That's a pretty big statement,
isn't it?
How is the crime on weld people's head that nobody sees other than the second
other words?
We don't really appreciate it.
On tennis,
gone on to that.
Cardiac surgeon says,
if you don't make big changes,
I ain't going to have to operate until somebody says,
actually,
you're moving towards type two diabetes or until the personal trainer says your
body fat is on the,
on CF territory.
You're not creeping into 15 1617 18% and beyond.
It's easier today.
It'd be healthy than at any stage in history.
Unfortunately in Ireland and you guys are based in Ireland,
we're really losing the obesity epidemic.
We're losing it badly.
We don't need very advanced technology.
All we need is simple,
a skipping rope,
a Kettlebell at home,
a bicycle to work in the morning,
a set of land skills,
good food.
We don't need a lot of really cool,
sexy equipment set of dumbbells.
Look at your diary,
plan out your month,
get your hardware checked on a regular basis,
use your smart technology even for motivation,
eat good food,
measure stuff regularly and obviously use wearable technology.
All of that equipment you could buy for about 150 bucks Max.
How many of you need to get much more focused on that before we move towards
year end and not even waiting until we start on January one or two.
Hands up nice and high please.
So I'm going to give you a bit five top tips in this capacity.
And the five top tips are grounded in the best practice in the world in terms of
longevity,
but also in terms of wellness.
Top tip one,
you need to eat well.
90% of the time.
Top tip to you need to be exercising five times a week for a minimum of 35
minutes and you need to move constantly.
Top tip number three is you're asleep.
As we say in high performance sport,
you're asleep is this secret silver bullet.
If you're not getting your sleep,
it's going to impact all other aspects of performance and your health.
Top tip number four is very much manage your stress.
I don't even need to look at this anymore.
Manage your stress.
Shattered me.
Scream at me.
Please are whisper at me.
How can you manage stress better?
Cool.
Meditation.
Who said meditation?
First of all,
this lady hit my phone.
Who is it for you?
Then
I'm going to give you the credit anyway.
Somebody else over here said meditation.
Who was that?
Good man.
Yeah,
you give it to somebody at home and Masa.
Rhino clause.
Okay,
nice.
Meditation.
If there's one tech at our ancient old ritual that I could stand over with 100%
certainty that it works with 98% of people meditation.
How many of you do meditation please?
Brilliant.
Please keep doing it.
Please bed into your everyday rituals for everybody else.
Please get curious about if there's a piece in the book about meditation on.
Finally,
I know it's for all you,
Gen x and Gen y.
It isn't so sexy and cool to talk about it,
but to watch your alcoholic,
don't we throw on those shots and the all the time a few glasses of wine are
very good,
your health,
but don't overdo it for obvious reasons.
So as we draw to a close that say in 2017 and November,
you're standing here on your thinking about what does the future hold for you?
Are you going to get mine?
You're not going to get mine.
You're going to have children or you're not gonna have children.
Are you going to stay on Google for next 10 years?
Are you going to go and start your own company?
Are you going to be really healthy,
are perhaps,
or you're not so sure about your future?
Three of the big lessons they would be given the o and m principals would be
number one,
your main set is going to be critical as you go on this journey,
make sure you've got the right mindset.
It's a bit like having the right equipment with you as you go in your journey.
Number two,
if you don't have the energy,
you're not going to be of the came nice and simple and you only have energy by
doing the physical exercise,
but eating well by sleeping well,
by hydrate,
unwell and so on.
If you don't have the energy,
you don't have the capacity as we say it to to work,
whether that's work time and through the mountains or whether that's work on
relationships,
whether that's work in sales or whether that's working in your technology.
Let's say challenges.
You need energy to do work.
The more energy have the more capacity.
How to do work,
that ass energy.
You have less capacity.
You have to do work.
I end of you to girl recently and she says,
I've got loads of energy.
I've got an unbelievable passion for what to do.
I says,
you must be fucking joke and I just,
low energy,
low capacity to do work.
There was nobody in the word who is not motivated.
They just have a friend that purpose yet.
Does that make sense to you?
If you're not motivated,
it's nothing wrong with you.
He was having fun.
In your purpose of defining your purpose,
you'll find passion and you find energy,
so your mission,
please get your mission sort of between nine year and don't wear it to new years
resolutions.
I'm pleased.
Have your small,
your medium and your big goals and I don't just mean your Google,
your Google goals.
What about your personal goals?
Maybe an unbelievable weekend again to where with your friends and the Alps and
March a once in a lifetime.
Maybe it is by this time next year you're going to have be promoted.
Maybe this time next year are going to be the best physical shape of your life.
Don't send me but ended up 35 and can't get on ship or on 45th there's around 76
on us.
They'll be them on.
I'm at Christmas time on.
I would tell them to get in the best shape of both mindset over matter.
We've got to finish it fun and the winners are this fun activity are going to
get about five books to bring home the family or friends or for yourselves or
work colleagues.
Is that fair enough?
Everybody on your feet quickly.
So first of all you're going to get in groups of five is,
but you must get your team to look like sound like a move,
like a high performance team.
It could be boxers are roars are simmers are cyclers,
but you must get them to move like signed,
like be like an almost look like a high performance team and grips of six is go
right.
I'm going to watch one group at a time.
I'm going to pick the three best scripts I named.
We're going to pick the singer Bass group.
Is that okay?
So if you guys do that in your hunger just to watch what's hop.
I Dunno what that has happened over here.
Southern really weird is Shannon's gone over here.
Okay,
please can you call it board of alphabet?
There's something really weird going on over here.
Okay,
go.
You guys were all busy and copper.
Vince,
Jack's last name.
Okay,
let's go in this gray beard that's go.
Hey
Maza.
Righto.
Pause.
Clean.
Okay.
I tell you that's an Irish Drogon cycling team.
I think there's a,
okay,
that's great.
Here please.
Three,
two,
one.
Okay.
Masada.
Applause please.
Let's grip.
Here
is gonna pick the winner.
By the way,
John has got to pick the winner.
Okay,
that's great.
I think it's fine.
Are you ready?
Masa and above queens
and that's great,
but when you go,
can you had a synchrony over that?
Not even get any of you that right now.
Pause next grade please correct me.
Unbelieving originality.
Okay,
great.
With the bag
right in over here.
Over here in the corner,
this goes or pollen.
What are the our writer
pause,
please
grab a seat.
Any real quick.
The guys want to close on a promise in the next 60 seconds or Charnay mark,
check me out.
Height.
Well done.
So guys,
what?
What Juan said,
he is.
Imagine that for the next week everybody in this room made a commitment to
challenge yourself and main set continually.
Whether it's getting feedback,
whether it's when you're walking to meet and go.
I'm going to try and be at my best in this meeting,
whether it's when you're in the gym this evening,
your trend,
bring your best energy into the gym rather than just in another gym session.
Imagine the next week you're only sick to eat good quality and you're only sick
to make sure you're having lots of water on board.
Obviously,
even if your social items that make sense.
So how have your few drinks but drink lots of water as well.
Imagine the next week that you make sure that you start to think about your
longterm goals for 2018 2019 and beyond,
right?
I'm watching in the next week.
You challenge yourself vigorously to go and get a coach.
I don't care why they get an internally or externally on.
Finally,
in the next week,
you create what I call a map,
a massive action plan about how to unlock your potential.
That's what commits abide,
a massive action plan of how you're gonna own luck.
The most potential you can possibly get out of yourselves.
Hands up on many things that would make a big impact in your life in a week and
never main and on the main in a year,
and I've made in 10 2030 years,
it'd be shown the agree.
Please scream yes and your language.
So my call to action is those seals.
People in the audience would know there must be a strong call to action at the
end of every session in the next week.
Can I ask you to take a massive action in terms of your main set massive action
in terms of your energy and your fitness,
your wellbeing and massive action in terms of actually having a big long term
goal on there for a mission that you're chasing hard after because it's much
easier to motivate yourself when you know what that is.
That is my simple call to action.
We're going to finish with 60 seconds.
We're going to blow this bloody roof off and 60 seconds in the islands there,
a purse,
the chairs,
and nice and tight,
please.
Okay?
You're going to get in your feet and you're going to shake.
Every single person has rooms hand,
but you're going do it in a very creative way.
It could be a high favor.
It could be a low five,
it could be jumping up and double high five.
But you must do with every single person,
the room.
Bring your best energy and bring a little bit of form,
a little bit of Flair,
and a little bit of creativity.
You've got 60 seconds to raise the roof off this building.
Go.
So
just for a bit of fun,
we're going to ask you to do it,
but five different poses.
Is that fair enough?
Okay,
so pose number one,
serious,
very serious.
Told.
Boring.
Okay.
Pose number two,
your APP to win the lottery
pose.
Number three is your old boxers
posing were for you?
Are you seeing bolts?
Unposed number five,
whatever you want yourselves.
Thank you very much guys for coming along today.